it's obvious that there's incredible
chaos going on in canada right now we
know that the trucker convoy got to
ottawa and they were met with the heavy
hand of the canadian government now
there's a lot of talk going on around
freedom and mandates and what should
actually be occurring and how the
government should be responding it
reminded me of this quote from epitus
that said is freedom anything else than
the right to live as we wish nothing
else and that's ultimately what i think
most citizens want is they simply want
to be left alone now there's been a lot
of hot takes on the internet lots of
viral tweets plenty of people advocating
for their view of the world but the
single best perspective that i've seen
is a recent post by david sacks where he
said a social credit system arrives in
canada now i'm not going to spend a
bunch of time reading everything but
there's four major points that i took
away the first is that for years
ideologues have used accusations of
bigotry to hound people from their jobs
kick them off social media and rescind
their right to participate in the online
economy however many observers shrugged
off these cases as outliers just fringe
examples that could be ignored because
they affected unsympathetic individuals
but now we have a wide ranging group of
working-class people and their
supporters who are being financially
deplatformed for civil disobedience so
how exactly is this possible well pretty
simply it's because the term terrorism
the definition of that word has been
expanded to include everything from
angry moms fighting school boards to
literally people just posting on the
internet now as sax clearly articulates
as we've seen over the last 20 years
terrorism is the magic word by which any
curtailment of rights and expansion of
government power can be justified
absolute insanity now if we go ahead and
we look that american citizens must
never be labeled terrorists simply for
exercising their constitutional rights
to speak freely to worship freely or to
assemble peacefully in protest of course
an act of violence committed in service
to a radical cause is terrorism whether
committed in baghdad or in brooklyn and
sax then finishes up his piece and he
says those of us in the free world have
been asked to suspend many of our
freedoms for the sake of our collective
health during this pandemic but asking
us to compromise our right to peaceful
protest or to have our finances seized
without due process of law in the name
of a fake emergency can never be made
normal in the words of justice gorset
even if the constitution has taken a
holiday during this pandemic it cannot
become a sabbatical now my takeaway from
all of this is that canada has awakened
the western world canada woke up the
west to the perils of financial
censorship and ultimately what we know
is that regardless of what your
government what your financial
institution wants to do to you even if
they continue to overreach if they
continue to encroach on your rights
there is now censorship resistant
technology bitcoin is unstoppable
bitcoin is inevitable and what we are
watching is that a decentralized digital
currency is being adopted by hundreds of
millions of people around the world
regardless of what your government does
regardless of what your bank does they
cannot stop you from buying selling
holding or transacting in a peer-to-peer
network with bitcoin and so ultimately
if you would not trust your enemy with
the power to conduct financial sanctions
or censorship then you shouldn't want
anyone to have those powers because
eventually they'll be turned against you
and at that moment you're gonna need
bitcoin start studying now start
learning bitcoin is freedom technology
and ultimately bitcoin will be in the
hands of everyone